ما تزال قوه الامن الاسرائيليه تجري
عمليات بحث ومطارده لمنفذ عمليه اطلاق
النار في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس بدايه
الاسبوع الحالي والتي ادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين كما تحصل القوات
الاسرائيليه مدينه اريحا وتعيق الدخول
والخروج منها بحثا عن خليه اطلقت النار
على مركبه اسرائيليه وقتلت سائقها ونفذ
الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله مداهمات واسعه
تخللها اعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين وسط
مواجهات شهدتها المدن الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه
ومن رام الله ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
ربما اخر الانباء
المتعلقه بهذا الامر صدرت عن الصحه
الفلسطينيه التي يعني ذكرت بان هناك اصابه
لثلاثه فلسطينيين في الاقتحام الاسرائيلي
لمخيم عقبه جابر باريح الاوضاع كيف يمكن
تقييمها اخر المعلومات كذلك
في هذا الاقتحام كان يخص الخليه
الفلسطينيه التي نفذت عمليه اطلاق نار قبل
يومين وعدت الى مقتل مستوطن بالقرب من
مدينه اريحا وذلك وفق وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
تقول ان القوه الاسرائيليه التي اقتحمت
مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا قبل نحو ساعه بشكل
مفاجئ قامت باغتيال احد الفلسطينيين وقامت
باعتقال عدد اخر من الفلسطينيين منهم من
نفذ عمليه اطلاق النار وتدعي وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه انها خليه تابعه خليه
مسلحه تابعه لحركه حماس هي التي نفذت هذه
العمليه وان هذا الهجوم كان يستهدف هذه
الخليه كان هناك محاصره لمنزل او منزلين
داخل مخيم عقبه جبر اطلقت الصواريخ
المحموله على الكتف من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه على المنزل ماده على ما يبدو
لاصابه عدد من الفلسطينيين واعتقال اخرين
وفق المصادر الفلسطينيه حتى الان فقط
اصابه واحده التي الى مستشفى اريح الحكومه
الاصابه الاخرى الخطيره اخذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي معه ولا يعرف ان كان هو احد
يعني الخليه المستهدفه ام شخص اخر يعني
شاب يمر في الطريق ولكن منع التواكم
الاسعاف من تقديم العلاج له واخذه الجنود
معهم الذين انسحبوا قبل دقائق فقط نايف
يعني انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من مخيم عقبه
جبر ووسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تقول ان
الحساب المفتوح مع هذه الخليه التي نفذت
هذه العمليه قد انتهى وبالتالي سنرى خلال
الساعات القادمه ان كان هناك ردود فعل
الفلسطينيه او ان كانت اسرائيل سوف تزيل
الحواجز التي كانت قد فرضتها على مدينه
اريحا خلال اليومين السابقين وكما تعرف
نايف يعني مدينه اريحة هي مدينه سياحيه
بالدرجه الاولى وهي بوابه الفلسطينيين الى
العالم كل فلسطيني يريد السفر عليها ان
يمر من مدينه اريحا وبالتالي كان هناك
اعاقات كبيره وتاثير بشكل مباشر على حياه
الناس الان العمليه العسكريه انتهت وتقول
اسرائيل انها
قامت باغتيال احد منفذي هذه العمليه
واعتقال اخرين واخذتهم الى مكان لاجراء
ومباشره عمليه الاغتيال هذا هذا حسب
المصادر الاسرائيليه الصحفيه يعني لا
تاكيدات من الصحه الفلسطينيه حول هذه
العمليه عمليه الاغتيال صاحب الفلسطينيه
تحدثت فقط عن ثلاثه اصابات
نعم عاده في مثل هذه الامور هناك اتصالات
تجري بين الارتباط الفلسطيني والارتباط
الاسرائيلي للتبليغ عن وقوع اصابات او
وقوع قتله وما الى ذلك ويبلغ الارتباط
الفلسطيني وزاره الصحه بشان الاصابات او
ان كان هناك ضحايا لهذا الهجوم ما وصلنا
من وزاره الصحه ان يعني هناك اتصالات تجري
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي لمعرفه نتائج هذه
العمليه لان الجنود عمليا قصفو المنزل
بصاروخ وحدث هناك اشتباك مسلح ولا نعرف من
اعتقل ومن اصيب ننقل عن وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بانه احد الشبان يعني احد
افراد هذه الخليه تم اغتياله في داخل
المنزل واعتقل اخرين ولكن ننتظر التاكيدات
الرسميه من وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه التي
عاده ما تتلقى هذه المعلومات من الجانب
الاسرائيلي الرسمي ماذا عن الوضع حتى هذه
اللحظه في في حواره عبد الحفيظ العاده
الحياتي لها حواره هل تم فتح المدينه مره
اخرى ام لا زالت مغلقه بسبب الاجراءات
والتدابير العسكريه هناك
يعني الامور تعود شيئا بشيء الى طبيعتها
اليوم جامعه النجاح اعلنت عن عوده الدوام
بشكل طبيعي ايضا بعض المدارس فتحت ابوابها
بعد ايام من الاغلاق نتيجه الاعتداءات
المستوطنين المتواصله ولكن ما زالت الخليه
او الشخص الذي نفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في
حواره وادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين ما زالت القوات الاسرائيليه تجري
عمليات بحث واسعه خلف هذا المنفذ وما زال
هناك يعني انتشار واسع وكثيف للجنود
الاسرائيليين سواء داخل بلده حواره او في
محيط هذه البلده ومحيط مدينه نابلس ما زال
الاهالي نايف في مدينه حواره لا ينامون
الليل ويسهرون طوال الليل خشيه من هجمات
انتقاميه اخرى للمستوطنين وبالتالي الامور
لم تعد الى طبيعتها ما دام هناك استنفار
اسرائيلي كبير ما دام هناك مستوطنون
يواصلون التهديد بالتنفيذ عمليات انتقاميه
ضد اهداف فلسطينيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ جاون